continuing with my search for massive
one-shot sniper hits in this video I'll
show you how to head up to two million
damage per shot using a bolt-action
sniper
[Music]
how long we've been out there and these
nights I can't sing shorter like a bad
night gee I'll conquer in my soul this
is real
these legs are getting short
unless
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
well looks like you don't need me I
guess I'll be the hill
[Music]
this is an updated version of the build
I released four or five weeks ago the
poor man's sniper build in that video of
showing how to hit numbers just over the
1 million mark through the use of the
ninja bike messenger bag and
non-classified set-pieces a month later
after a hell of a lot of grinding I now
have the full six piece classified did I
set like I said in the earlier video I'm
not a fan of Deadeye I like my headshots
to count and I love seeing those big
numbers pop up so I won't be building
the traditional did I build in fact
after a lot of playing around with it I
won't even be using the full six piece
set
bear with me though if you follow what I
show you here you should be landing up
to two million crits in no time there's
actually more opportunity to take this
number even higher for example equipping
a mobile cover and having a teammate
running a high skill power bill
providing max pulse will help but for
the purpose of this video I'll be
explaining it as a solo build a couple
of notes before I get started even
though we won't be using the Dead Eye
for its four-piece perk it'll still be
unlocked the four piece bonus states
when zoomed marksman rifles lose hit
shot bonus but gain fifty percent strike
chance when out of cover and 100 percent
strike chance when in cover so basically
it's quite important to remember not to
zoom in or you'll lose your headshot
damage shoulder the weapon only which is
fine on console as most of the time
you'll be snapping on and off the
shouldering to take advantage of the
order aim while we're talking about aim
the other thing that needs to be
mentioned is that unlike did I you need
to be able to hit your headshots only
having every second or third bullet
being a headshot will severely low your
damage output and I'll explain why very
soon
finally just because you'll be able to
hit these massive numbers doesn't mean
you'll be able to run around the DZ like
woods one shotting every player you see
though I have tried in PvP with a little
success it's a little bit too
situational and for this reason I would
state that this is build intended mainly
for PvE
as with all of my build videos if you're
trying to keep this as clear and concise
as possible the idea is for you to use
this as a starting point or a template
for your own build change things up and
personalize it for your style of play as
per usual I've included a cheat sheet at
the end of the video that sums up this
build and everything discussed here this
build consists of five piece classified
Deadeye and a reckless chest
the idea is to stack as much into
firearms headshot damage and critical
hit
damaged as possible full glass cannon
all gear pieces have been rolled into
firearms the major attributes you should
be aiming for our critical hit damage
kneepads backpack and gloves skill hast
body armor gloves and holster and skill
power mask the one minor attribute
that's a must is damage to elites mask
and knee pads usually critical hit
damage would be a bad call and a waste
of an attribute in comparison to other
options but because of the nature of
this build critical hit damages
converted directly into damage so nine
percent critical hit damage can be
considered as a nine percent damage
increase all gear mods are firearms with
increased damage to elites all
performance mods are pulse critical hit
damage applying the above should leave
you with around 10k firearms 200%
headshot damage and 140 percent Plus
critical hit damage the equipped skills
are tactical scanner and booster shot
tactical scanner for an increase in
critical hit damage and boosts the shop
for a further increase in damage
feeding into skill haste will allow you
to have these running more often
the two talents I would call a must
critical save and strike back to help
get you out of those sticky situations
if your health gets low the other two
slots are optional here I'm using
tactical advanced and precision for even
more damage
tactical advance comes highly
recommended because you'll be quite
squishy you'll be forced to play this
game as a cover shooter weird right so
if you can adjust your play style to
utilize the cover to cover more often
this will be a good constant boost to
your damage the primary weapon I'm using
is the custom m-44 and here's where
things go a little different from the
standard did I build nothing up until
this point has been placed into critical
hit chance so one of the skills on this
weapon is an absolute requirement of
this build disciplined killing a target
will make your next shot with the weapon
be an automatic critical hit so of this
triggered which can be reasonably easy
with a bolt-action sniper and landing
consistent headshots you'll be mowing
down a pcs left right and center
personally I still haven't managed to
find the best sniper but the perfect
weapon would be a bolt-action sniper
with high base damage disciplined
prepared for the multiplicative damage
increase and deadly for the further
increase in critical hit damage brutal
is another option but to get a good idea
of how the different attributes work
with additive and multiplicative damage
I'd suggest watching a video that was
recently released by Marko style I'll
link it in the description below the
secondary weapon is really up to you I'd
recommend a closer combat weapon for
anything that manages to rush you down
but if you're confident with your
sniping you may choose to use a higher
rate of fire marksman rifle here I'm
using the lightweight m4
so that's it I'll continue with my quest
of finding bigger headshot hits with the
sniper but if you have any suggestions
let me know I'm trying out a new format
for my build videos still trying to keep
them short and sweet but without missing
out too much of the vital information
let me know what you think if you'd like
to see more of this type of content
subscribe to the channel and leave a
comment below
and if you'd like to see me playing live
you can often find me teaming up with my
magnet tail gain on his stream Friday
and Saturday night New Zealand Australia
time yeah I know exciting Friday night
but hey keeps me out of trouble anyway a
linkers twitch in the description below
thanks
you
[Music]